it's been I think three years since the
Jeffrey Epstein controversy at MIT MIT
media lab Joy Edo the head of uh the
media lab resigned
and I think at that time you were an
opinion article about it
so just looking back a few years have
passed what
what have you learned about human nature
um
from the fact that somebody like Jeffrey
Epstein
found his way inside MIT
it's a really good question what have I
learned about human nature
I think
well there's
there's how did this problem come about
and then there's what was the reaction
to this problem and to it becoming
public
and in the reaction
the things I learned about human nature
were that sometimes cowards are worse
than [ __ ]
[Laughter]
wow I'm really oh
I mean that's a really powerful
statement
I think because
you know what you're doing with
they have Integrity in a way
waving out their [ __ ] values yeah and
the cowards are the ones that you have
to watch out for and this comes back to
people protecting themselves over
doing the right thing
um
they'll throw others under the bus
is there some sense that not enough
people took responsibility
for sure and I mean
I don't want to sugarcoat at all what
Joey Ito did I mean
I think it's gross that he took money
from Jeffrey Epstein I believe him that
he didn't know about the bad bad stuff
but I've been in those circles with
those like
public intellectual dudes that he was
hanging out with and
any woman in those circles like thought
10 zillion red flags just the whole
environment was so misogynist like
and so personally because Joey like was
a great boss and a great friend it
I was really disappointed that he
ignored that in favor of raising money
um
and I think that it was right for him to
resign
in the face of that but
one of the things that he did that know
many others didn't was he came forward
about it and he took responsibility
and all of the people who didn't I think
it's just interesting the other thing I
learned about human nature okay I'm
gonna go on on a tangent but I'll come
back I promise so I once saw this tweet
from someone or was a Twitter thread
from someone who worked at a homeless
shelter and he said that
when he started working there he noticed
that people would often come in and use
the bathroom and they would just trash
the entire bathroom like rip things out
of the walls like toilet paper on the
ground and he asked someone who had been
there longer like why do they do this
why do the homeless people come in and
trash the bathroom and he was told it's
because it's the only thing in their
lives that they have control over
and I feel like
sometimes when it comes to
the response the
just the the mobbing response that
happens in the wake of
some harm that was caused
if you can't Target the person who
actually caused the harm who was Epstein
you will go as many circles out as you
can until you find the person that you
have power over and you have control
over and then you will trash that and it
makes sense that people do this it's
again it's a human nature thing of
course you're going to focus all your
energy because you feel helpless and
enraged and you and it's unfair and you
have no other power
you're going to focus all of your energy
on someone who's so far removed from the
problem that that's not even an
efficient solution
and the problem is often the the first
person you find is the one that has
Integrity sufficient Integrity take
responsibility yeah and it's why my
husband always says he's he is a liberal
but he's always like
when liberals form a firing squad they
stand in a circle because you know that
your friends are going to listen to you
so you criticize them you're not going
to be able to convince someone across
the aisle but see in that situation what
I had hoped is the people in the farther
in that situation any situation of that
sort the people that are farther out in
the circles
uh stand up yes and like it also take
some responsibility for the broader
picture of human nature versus like
specific situation
but also
take some responsibility
and um
but also defend the people involved as
flawed not in a like no no no nothing
like like this people [ __ ] up like you
said there's a lot of red flags that
people just ignored for the sake of
money in this particular case
but also like be transparent and public
about it and spread the responsibility
across large number of people such that
you learn a lesson from it
institutionally
yeah it was a systems problem it wasn't
a one individual problem and I feel like
currently
because Joey took like resigned because
of it or essentially fired pressured out
because of it uh MIT can pretend like oh
we didn't we didn't know anything it
wasn't part bad leadership again because
when you are at the top of an
institution with that much power and you
were complicit in what happened which
they were
like come on there's no way that they
didn't know that this was happening so I
like to not stand up and take
responsibility
I think it's bad leadership do you
understand why Epstein was able to
um
outside of MIT he was able to make a lot
of friends
with a lot of powerful people does that
make sense to you why was he able to get
in these rooms befriend these people but
friend people that I don't know
personally but I think a lot of them
indirectly I know as being good people
smart people
why would they let Jeffrey Epstein into
the into their office have a discussion
with them what what do you understand
about human nature from that well
so I never met Epstein or
I mean
I've met some of the people who
interacted with him but I I was never
like I never saw him in action I don't
know how charismatic he was or what that
was but I do think that sometimes the
simple answer is the more likely one and
from my understanding what he would do
is he was kind of a grift a social
grifter like
you know those people who will
you must get this because you're famous
you must get people coming to you and
being like Oh I know your friends so and
so in order to get cred with you
um
I think he just
convinced some people who were trusted
in a network that he was a great guy and
that you know whatever I think at that
point because at that point he had had
like a what a conviction prior but it
was a one-off thing it wasn't clear that
there was this other thing that was that
and most people probably don't check
yeah and most people don't check like
you're on an event you meet this guy I
don't know maybe people do check when
they're that powerful and wealthy or
maybe they don't I have no idea no
they're just stupid I I mean they're not
like
all right well like does anyone check
anything about me because I've walked
into some some of the richest the most
popular powerful people in the world and
nobody like asks questions like who the
[ __ ] is this guy
like yeah like nobody asks those
questions it's it's interesting I get I
I would think like there would be more
security or something like there there
it really isn't I think a lot of it has
to do well my hope is in my case has to
do with like people can sense that this
is a good person but
if that's the case then they can surely
then a human being can use charisma
to infiltrate yeah it's just being just
saying people vouching for you within
that type of network like once you yeah
once you have someone powerful vouching
for you who someone else trusts then you
know
you're in
so how do you avoid something like that
if you're MIT if you're Harvard if
you're any of these institutions well I
mean first of all you have to do your
homework before you take money from
someone
um like I think I think that's required
but I think you know I think Joey did do
his homework I think he did and I think
at the time that he took money
there was the one conviction and not
like the later thing and I think that
the story at that time was that
he didn't know she was underage and lava
and or whatever it was a mistaken Joey
always believed in Redemption for people
and that people can change and that they
can genuinely regret and like learn and
and move on and he was a big believer in
that so I could totally see him being
like well I'm not gonna exclude him
because of this thing
and because other people are vouching
for him so
and
just to be clear we're now talking about
the set of people who I think Joy
belonged to who did not like go to the
island and have sex with underage girls
because that's a whole other set of
people who like
were powerful and like were part of that
Network and who knew and participated
and and so like I distinguish between
people who got taken in who didn't know
that that was happening and people who
knew I wonder what the different circles
look like so like people that went to
the island
and then didn't do anything it didn't
see anything didn't know about anything
versus the people that did something and
then there's people who heard rumors
maybe and what do you do with rumors
like isn't there isn't there people that
uh heard rumors about Bill Cosby for the
longest time
for like for the longest like whenever
that happened
like all these people came out of the
woodwork like everybody kind of knew
um I mean this it's like all right so
what are you supposed to do with rumors
like what uh I think the other way to
put is red flags as you were saying yeah
and like I could tell you that those
circles like there were red flags
without me even hearing any rumors about
anything ever like I was already like
hmm
there are not a lot of women here which
is a bad sign
isn't there a lot of places where
there's not a lot of women and that
doesn't necessarily mean it's a bad sign
there are if it's like a pipeline
problem where it's like
I don't know technology law clinic that
only gets like male lawyers because
there's all there's not a lot of women
you know applicants in the pool but
there's some aspect of this situation
that like there should be more women
here oh yeah
you've uh
actually I'd love to ask you about this
because uh you have strong opinions
about Richard stallman
is that do you still have those strong
opinions look all I need to say is that
he met my friend who's a law professor
yeah
she shook his hand and he licked her arm
from wrist to elbow and it certainly
wasn't appropriate at that time
what about if you're like
an incredibly weird person
okay the
there's a lot of
Divergence and
and everywhere
we need to accept that people are
different that people don't understand
social conventions the same way but one
of the things that I've learned about
neurodivergence is that
women are often
expected or taught to mask their
neurodivergence and kind of fit in and
men are accommodated and excused and I
don't think that
being neurodivergent gives you a license
to be an [ __ ] like you can be a weird
person and you can still learn that it's
not okay to lick someone's arm
yeah there's it's a balance like women
should be allowed to be a little weirder
and men should be less weird because I
think I think there's uh because I
you're one of the people I think
tweeting that
what made me because I wanted to talk to
Richard Stoneman on the podcast
about because I didn't have a context
because I wanted to talk to him because
he's you know free software he's very
he's very weird
in interesting good ways in the world of
computer science
he's also weird in that you know when he
gives a talk he'll be like uh like
picking at his feet and eating the skin
off his feet right that he's known for
these extremely kind of
how else do you put it I don't know how
to put it but then there was um
something that happened to him in
conversations on this thread related to
Epstein yeah which I was torn about
because I felt it's similar to Joy uh
you know it's like I felt he was
maligned like uh people were looking for
somebody to get angry at so he he was
inappropriate but the
um
I didn't like the cowardice more like I
I set aside
his his situation and we could discuss
it but the the cowardice on mit's part
and this is me saying it about the way
they treated that whole situation oh
they're always
copied anything they should try to make
the problem go away yeah so that it was
it was about yeah exactly the
conversation I think he should have left
the mailing
so you shouldn't have he shouldn't have
been part of the mailing well that's
probably true also but I think I I think
what what bothered me what always
bothers me in these mailing list
situations or Twitter situations like
if you say something
that's hurtful to people or makes people
angry and then people start yelling at
you
maybe they shouldn't be yelling
maybe they are yelling because
again you're the only point of power
they have
maybe maybe it's okay that they're
yelling whatever it is like
it's your response to that that matters
and I think that I just have a lot of
respect for people
who can say
oh people are angry
there's a reason they're angry let me
find out what that reason is and learn
more about it
it doesn't mean that I am wrong it
doesn't mean that I am bad it doesn't
mean that I'm ill-intentioned but
why are they angry I want to understand
and then once you understand you can
respond again with integrity and say
actually I stand by what I said here's
why or you can say actually I listened
and here are some things I learned
that's the kind of response I want to
see from people and people like stallman
do not respond that way they just like
go into battle
right like where it's obvious you you
didn't listen yeah no I'm just in
listening honestly that's to me as bad
as the people who just apologize just
because they are trying to make the
problem go away of course
all right so like if that's not both as
bad a good apology has to include
understanding what you did wrong and in
part standing up for the things you
think you did right so yeah if there are
those things yeah finding and then but
you have to give
you have to acknowledge you have to like
give that hard hit to the ego that says
I did something wrong yeah that
definitely wishes Thomas not somebody
who's
capable of that kind of thing or hasn't
given evidence of that kind of thing
um but that was also even just your
tweet I had to do a lot of thinking like
different people from different walks of
life see red flags and different things
yes
and so
things I find
um
as a as a man non-threatening and
hilarious
are not necessarily
um
doesn't mean that they're
aren't like deeply hurtful to others and
I don't mean that in the social justice
Warrior way but in a in a in a real way
like people really have different
experiences so I have to like really put
things into context
um I have to kind of listen to what
people are saying put aside the emotion
of what their emotion will do what
you're saying it and try to keep the the
facts of their experience and learn from
it and because it's not just about the
in
the experience either it's not like oh
you know my friend didn't have a sense
of humor about being licked
it's that she's been she's been
metaphorically licked you know 57 times
that week because she's an attractive
law professor and she doesn't get taken
and so like men walk through the world
and it's impossible for them to even
understand what it's like
to have a different experience of the
world and that's why it's so important
to listen to people and believe people
and believe that they're angry for a
reason maybe you don't like their tone
maybe you don't like that they're angry
at you maybe you get defensive about
that maybe you think that they should
you know explain it to you
but believe that they're angry for a
reason and try to understand it yeah
there's a deep truth there and an
opportunity for you to become a better
person
can I ask you a question haven't you
been doing that for two hours laughs
three hours now okay uh let me ask you
about uh Elaine Maxwell she's been
saying that she's an innocent victim
uh is she an innocent victim or is she
uh evil and equally responsible like
Jeffrey Epstein now I'm asking far away
from any MIT things and more just your
sense of the whole situation I haven't
been following it so I don't know the
facts of the situation and like what is
now like known to be her role in that if
I were her clearly I'm not but if I were
her I wouldn't be going around saying
I'm an innocent victim I would say
maybe she's I don't know what she said
again like I don't know she was
controlled by Jeffrey is she saying this
as part of a legal case or is she saying
this as like a PR thing uh well
PR but it's not just her it's her whole
family believes this there's uh there's
a whole effort that says like
that
how should I put it I believe they
believe it so in that sense it's not PR
I I I believe the family basically the
family is saying that
she's a good she's a really good human
being well I think everyone is a good
human being I know it's the
controversial opinion but I think
everyone
is a good human being
there's no evil people there's people
who do bad things and who behave in ways
that harm others and I think we should
always hold people accountable for that
but holding someone accountable doesn't
mean saying that they're evil yeah
actually those those people usually
think they're doing good
yeah I mean aside from I don't know
maybe sociopaths like are specifically
trying to like harm people
but I think most people are trying to do
their best and if they're not
doing their best is because there's some
impediment or something in their past
so I I just I genuinely don't believe in
good and evil people but I do believe in
like harmful and not harmful actions and
so I don't know like I don't care I
don't care yeah she's a good person but
if she contributed to harm then she
needs to be accountable for that like
that's my position I don't know what the
facts of the matter are it seems like
she was pretty close to the situation so
it doesn't seem very believable that she
was a victim but I don't know
I wish I have met Epstein
because something tells me he would just
be a regular person a charismatic person
like anybody else and that's a very dark
reality that we don't know which Among
Us
what what each of us are hiding in the
closet
that's a really tough thing to like deal
with because then you can put your trust
into some people
and they can completely betray that
trust and in the process destroy you
yeah which there's a lot of people that
interacted with Epstein
that now have to
I mean if they're not destroyed by it
then they're they that their whole like
the ground on which they stand ethically
is is has crumbled at least in part
and you I'm sure
I'm sure you and I have interacted with
people without knowing it who are bad
people
as I always tell my four-year-old people
who have done bad things people heard um
bad things because I was talking about
bad guys and I'm trying to move him
towards
they're just people who make bad choices
yeah that's really powerful actually
that's really important to remember
because that that means you have
compassion towards all human beings
um do you have hope for the future of
MIT a future of media lab in this
context
uh so David Newman is now at the helm
I'm gonna talk I talked to a priest I'll
talk to her again
she's great love her yeah she's great
I don't know if she knew
situation when she started because
the situation went beyond just the
Epstein Scandal a bunch of other stuff
happened at the same time
some of it's not public
um
but my what I was personally going
through at that time so the Epstein
thing happened I think was it August or
September
2019 it was somewhere around late summer
in June 2019
so I'm I'm a research scientist at MIT
you are too right so and I always have
had various supervisors uh you know over
the years and they've just basically let
me do what I want which has been great
but I had a supervisor at the time
and he called me into his office for
regular check-in
in June of 2019 I reported to MIT that
my supervisor had
grabbed me
pulled me into a hug wrapped his arms
around my waist and started massaging my
hip and trying to kiss me kiss my face
kiss me near the mouth
um and said literally the words don't
worry I'll take care of your career
um and that
that experience was really interesting
because I just
I was very indignant I was like
she can't do that to me doesn't he know
who I am and I was like this is the me
too era and I naively thought that when
I reported that it would get taken care
of and then I had to go through the
whole reporting process at MIT and I
learned a lot about how institutions
really handle those things internally
um particularly situations where I
couldn't provide evidence that it
happened I had no reason to lie about it
but I had no evidence and so I was going
through that and that was another
experience for me where
there's so many people in the
institution
who really believe in protecting the
institution at all costs and there's
only a few people who care about doing
the right thing
and one of them
resigned now there's even less of them
left so
what'd you learn from that
I mean where is the source if you have
hope
for this institution that I think you
love
at least in part
I I love the idea of MIT I love the idea
I love the research body I love a lot of
the faculty I love the students the
students I love the energy like I love
it all I think the administration
suffers from the same problems as
any
institutional any leadership of an
institution that is large
which is that
they've become risk-averse like you
mentioned they care about PR the only
ways to
get their attention or change their
minds about anything or to threaten the
reputation of The Institute or to have a
lot of money
that's the only way to have power at the
Institute
um
yeah I don't think they I don't think
they have a lot of Integrity or believe
in ideas or even have a lot of
connection to the research body and like
the people who are really because it's
so weird you have this amazing research
body of people pushing the boundaries of
things who aren't afraid to like there's
the hacker culture
and then you have the administration and
they're really like
protect the institution at all costs
yeah there's a disconnect right complete
I wonder if that was those there if it
just kind of slowly grows over time a
disconnect between the administration
The Faculty I think it grew over time is
what I've heard
I mean I've been there for 11 years now
I don't know if it's gotten worse during
my time but
I've heard from people who've been there
longer that it didn't know like MIT
didn't used to have a general counsel's
office they didn't used to have all this
corporate stuff and then they had to
create it as they got bigger and in the
era where such things are I guess deemed
necessary see I believe in the power of
individuals to like overthrow the thing
so it's just a really good president
of MIT or certain people in the
administration can reform the whole
thing because the the culture is still
there of like
I think everybody
remembers that MIT is about the students
and the faculty do they though because
I don't know I've had a lot of
conversations that have been shocking
with like senior Administration they
think the students are children they
call them kids it's like these are the
smartest people they're way smarter than
you yeah and you're so dismissive but
those individuals I'm saying like the
the capacity
like the aura of the place
still values this the students and and
the faculty like I I'm not I'm being
awfully poetic about it but what I mean
is the administration is the um
the froth at the top of the like the
waves the surface like they can be
removed and New Life can be brought in
that would keep to the spirit of the
place who decides on who to bring in
who's coming up oh I see
uh I see but I I do think ultimately
especially in the era of social media
and so on
um
faculty and students have more and more
power just more and more of a voice I
suppose I hope so I really do
I don't see MIT going away anytime soon
and like I also don't think it's a
terrible place at all yeah it's an
amazing place and it's uh but there's
different trajectories you can take yeah
and like and that has to do with a lot
of things including
um
does it is it stays even if you talk
about robotics it could be the capital
of the world in robotics
um but currently if you want to be doing
the best AI work in the world you're
going to go to Google or Facebook
um or Tesla or apple or so on you're not
going to be you're not going to be an
MIT
and so that that has to do I think
that's basically has to do with
um
not allowing the the Brilliance of the
researchers to flourish
yeah people say it's about money but I
don't think it's about that at all like
sometimes you have more freedom and can
work on more interesting things in
companies that's really where they lose
people yeah and so the the freedom in
all in in all ways
which is why it's heartbreaking to get
like people like Richard stallman this
such an interesting line because like
Christian Thomas a gigantic weirdo that
cross lines you shouldn't across right
but we don't want to draw too many lines
this is the tricky thing there are
different types of lines in my opinion
but just your opinion because you have
strong lines you hold through but then
if Administration listens to every line
there's there's also power in drawing a
line
like and there's it becomes like a
little drug you have to find the right
balance licking somebody's arm is never
appropriate I think the biggest aspect
there is not uh owning it learning from
it growing from it from a perspective of
stallmen or people like that uh back
when it happened like understanding
seeing the right being empathetic seeing
the the fact that this was like totally
inappropriate
uh like not when that particular act but
everything that led up to it too no I
know I crossed lines that
essentially excluded a bunch of people
and created an environment where we
their Brilliant Minds that we never got
the benefit of because he made things
feel
gross or even unsafe for people there
are lines that you can cross where
you're challenging an institution to
like I don't think he was intentionally
trying to cross a line or maybe he maybe
he didn't care there are lines that you
can cross intentionally to move
something forward or to do the right
thing like when MIT was like you can't
put an all-gender restroom in the media
lab because like something permits
whatever
and Joey did it anyway that's a line you
can cross to make things actually better
for people and the line you're Crossing
is some arbitrary stupid rule that
people who don't want to take the risk
or like
uh yeah for sure you know what I mean no
ultimately I think the thing you said is
like cross lines in a way that doesn't
uh
uh alienate others so like for example
me weren't I started for a while wearing
a suit often at MIT which sounds
counter-intuitive but that's actually
um
people always looked at me weird for
that MIT created this culture
specifically the people I was working
with like nobody wore a suit maybe we
don't trust the thief don't trust the
suits I was like [ __ ] you I'm wearing a
suit
that's not really hurting anybody right
exactly
um it's challenging people's perceptions
it's doing something that you want to do
yeah but it's not hurting people and and
that that particular thing was
um yeah it's hurting people
it's a good line it's a good line to
like
hurting ultimately the people that you
want to flourish